ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata la ricetta che
faremo oggi non ha veramente tantissimo
senso però poi ci siamo alla fine detti
insomma che non è che ci sono tante cose
che al mio senso all'interno di questo
format anche perché questo piatto
all'interno del suo nome contiene tre
delle cose che mi piacciono di più
alunno sushi è meraviglioso la nutella e
formidabile e la banana beh chi non ama
la banana per farlo in breve oggi
prepareremo il banana nutella sushi sono
tre cose che viste insieme
già mi trasmettono ferrante anche tu con
quei pantaloncini mi trasmetti un senso
aberrante si sa instagram può essere un
grandissimo alleato o un grandissimo
nemico oggi ha giocato al nostro favore
perché perché questa qui è una di quelle
ricette virali che vanno su instagram è
che tendenzialmente sono divertenti da
vedere quindi mi sono detto che proviamo
a farla fare questo piatto è veramente
facilissimo avrete bisogno di banana
ne prendo tre così almeno una la mangio
nutella e riso soffiato faccio rimasto
male
per prima cosa prendiamo il riso
soffiato per te cospargono il ripiano lo
sapete che se noi stessi in una piazza e
facesse questo avremmo uno stormo di
piccioni addosso prendiamo l'unica
banana rimasta a questo punto quello che
fanno loro e questo e tolgono solamente
una parte poggiano la buccia piena di
schifo sopra il riso soffiato e con un
coltello
il nuovo
andrea
non se ne stiamo facendo uno spot uno
spot alla nutella ma non si può non c'è
terreno quando volete
prendiamo la nutella e cospargiamo la
sulla banana a questo punto prendere e
fare così inutilmente perché poi
dobbiamo fare così fondamentalmente poi
quello che si fa e questo si toglie un
altro pezzo di buccianti tredicenne un
perito non potete leggerlo prima no la
terna a questo punto se funziona è
un'ottima merenda da fare una volta
all'anno
prendiamo la pellicola tiriamo via tutto
sì ma ha senso questa roba
tu come avresti fatto c'è un modo per
farlo meglio tutto molto bravo non fare
i danni che altro è il procedimento
giusto sento al sicuro sembra compreso
lo stronzo dello spalmatoio sempre nella
chiave da una certa distanza e anche
portato di spalle però c'è non lo devi
vedere e se l'insieme si infligge un po
perché il tema di un po il frizzantino è
finita cioè non hai cucinato niente ma
ragazzi mica dobbiamo far vedere quanto
siamo bravi
l'anno scorso la spesa per quello
dimostrato che impossibile ma creiamo la
salsa nutella intanto quindi una volta
calorica zio poco enrico errico che a
dieta questo è per il ricoperta per non
influire per the viper rico
il cuore enrico dai basta interno sta
tornando questo lo stato della
particolare perché sennò si scompatta
sarà nutella riso soffiato e banale no
farà schifo che ne sono alieni
l'accoppiata non funziona perché le
persone si inventano queste cose per
fare laico che faccio un tortino con la
più di con tortino dai un po forte come
affermazione non trovi
sam e tante canale di gola
stronzo non doveva andare così era
partiti
prendiamo un pochino di lavarsi le mani
[Musica]
allora ragazzi venite ad assaggiare il
mezzo stai aia che con le bacchette con
lo scopettone del bader ragazzi guardate
che cosa ho trovato è di colore diverso
mi piace di una posizione di kakà ma
comunque nessuno di non far l'accoppiata
vi è fatto e poi l'ultimo è che se avete
colori diversi queste metto un po di
salsa di soia insomma queste cose sarà
buonissimo nov
per riuscire a rovinare
non so o senza banana news ed a
cucchiaiate se volete fate prima a
napoli
se volete farlo l'academy su instagram
non dimenticate di iscrivervi al canale
attivare sulla campanella delle
notifiche per poi sotto se avete dei
suggerimenti per the video un futuro
mette temi sempre un pollice su per
questo video hanno una bandana me ci
vediamo la prossima domenica sempre alle
ciao
e comunque aveva un utilizzo migliore
della banana di un prete gettati nel
monte fato
[Risate]